West Virginia's public schools are
closed for a third day after an historic
statewide teacher walkout educators and
supporters held the candlelight vigil at
the State Capitol last night they're
calling for better pay and benefits the
National Education Association says West
Virginia's teachers are the 48th lowest
paid in the country they receive an
average annual salary of just over
$45,000 that's nearly $13,000 below the
national average Don Dahler was at the
State Capitol in Charleston where
teachers will protest for a fifth day
Don good morning good morning this
walkout is expected to impact more than
a quarter million students almost 20,000
teachers from all across the state are
taking part in the very first statewide
teacher strike in West Virginia history
our teachers are our public employees
are getting less and pay per year every
year and people are fed up and fired up
about it
teachers in West Virginia are demanding
state lawmakers take action to protect
educators for United we're all standing
strong teachers service personnel we are
here and we are going to stay
we need Charleston to wake up and smell
the coffee the statewide walkout began
Thursday one day after legislators
passed a bill that would give teachers
their first raise in four years it
includes a four percent increase over
the next three years but teachers argue
it is not enough and won't offset rising
health care costs we're looking at
insurance rates going from a hundred and
seventy-eight dollars per month to four
hundred twelve dollars per month that's
a car payment
with no car in sight that's food off my
table
the teachers union says it will not back
down until its demands are met we have
to see a real strong commitment we're
asking to move us in the right direction
and to take care of our health insurance
at a level that we can see our cheques
go up not have them go down while this
is the first statewide teacher walkout a
majority of West Virginia counties went
on strike in 1990 to protest low pay the
11 day strike ended with salary
increases and new support programs in
schools we can't keep watching all of
our colleagues go out of state because
they can make a living wage we want to
stay here we want to be with our
students and our students deserve that
education more than two hundred and
seventy-seven thousand students will be
out of school for a third day but
parents are showing their support this
whole situation is difficult for
everyone but I believe that this is all
for the right reason I think we need to
make education our top priority we need
to invest in our children and encourage
people to stay here and then maybe we
can be a wealthy state this work
stoppage is actually illegal under West
Virginia law the state's attorney
general says while he does support the
teachers cries for higher salaries he
says he is going to help local law
enforcement enforce the rule of law now
the teachers union says their lawyers
are ready to handle any challenge
Noora all right Don thank you I tell you
what they are bringing attention to that
how much or how little they're making
well you know we asked teachers to do so
much it's not just about math and
history we asked them to have authority
to deal with students and this sends a
message about how much authority
everybody thinks students should have we
we value what we pay for so there's a
bigger message to being sent here to